where is the Amazon located
maybe a geography book sure
how many stars on the American flag
[__] we got 13 colonies on
130 got down 47.
what would you be willing to give up to
save the homo sapiens great question
thank you
I think you just give it your heart you
get what you feel
would you do a hundred dollars a month
say probably
50. who do you think smarter people from
New York or people from La uh L.A why do
you say that
um just because that's I'm from
California
what does IQ stand for IQ yeah
um intelligence
quiz uh what does SAT stand for
standardized assessment test
what does SAT stand for
I have no idea
have you ever taken them no
hi what's your name Taylor Brown Taylor
okay and when you're a college student
yes at Howard University oh very good
what does NATO stand for
NATO
stands for
new automobile dealership
a case no no what is
r-o-f-l-a-l-m-a-o stand for rolling on
the floor laughing my ass off how many
letters in the alphabet girl 52 how many
letters in the alphabet I think 24. oh
my God
27. finish of course Give me liberty or
give me death very good
you know who said it
um oh gosh
no
I do but I don't Samuel Jackson Samuel L
Jackson
[Applause]
farmer has 17 cheap all but nine of them
are eaten by Wolves how many sheep does
he have left
[Music]
uh you're in a pizzeria
there are 17 slices okay all but nine
get eaten
how many slices are left
um
eleven eight nine and seven and sixteen
nine oh man I'm panicking when you're a
citizen of the United States I shall
right Warren here sure it sure was what
country did we fight in the
Revolutionary War
France
and all but nine of them Get Smoked by
him how many joints does he have left
eight uh a farmer has 17 sheep all but
nine of them get eaten by Wolves how
many sheep does he have left
uh that is definitely a trick question
yes it is
um wolves don't eat sheep oh it's not
that kind of a turquoise oh
hold on okay um Nancy
my full name or just my first name Nancy
and I am a bartender
yeah
right
can you name all five oceans for me oh
come on
Atlantic there's the Gulf of Mexico
uh Mediterranean Sea right and when
I've heard of the Black Sea a farmer has
17 Kardashians all but nine of them get
eaten by Wolves how many Kardashians
does he have left
nine
I think that's what it is yeah you're
right we're talking about cyber security
today and how safe people's passwords
are what is one of your online passwords
currently it's like my cat's name and
then just like a random number okay is
if you had this cat for a while yeah
which is my childhood pet oh and what's
her name her name is Jolie Jolie so like
a password of yours would be Jolie and
then a number yeah like number one uh
like by birthday oh when is your
birthday uh June 12th oh nice what your
reborn uh 95. oh great so Jolie six
12.95 yes got it what is the object of
Angry Birds Birds on your iPhone and you
pull it back and then shoot
shoot are there any pigs or anything
like that at all pigs yeah and like some
things get you points okay when you win
the game what is our objective in
Afghanistan
to get oil that's not ours no no I would
stick with the Angry Birds Angry Birds
can you name all seven continents on the
Earth
Egypt
I was Egypt one no hold on come on
Europe Australia Antarctica
Egypt
um
I don't know we have to find a way to
live with the homo sapiens in a way
where we don't you know they don't
affect us we won't affect them kind of
like in a separation type of way
I don't know what a homo sapien is if
they're going extinct that's very sad
but at the end of the day I don't care
it's not the fact that I don't like Homo
sapiens it's just that we've always
lived without him so we don't know
anything at all I'm a school teacher at
Orange Center Elementary in Fresno
California and you're a citizen of the
United States yes I am when was the
Declaration of Independence adopted
still awake yes
yes who said Give me liberty or give me
death oh
oh that's very dramatic to portrayal
with oh I like the hands I'm not good
with names only my own and my students
okay well you should but that's you now
if you if a student said that to you I'm
not good with names you would give them
an F now come on
um who said Give me liberty or give me
death
I'll give you a hint yes Bonaparte is
not even America
country right now that's been all over
the news Trump tweets about it a lot we
want to know if Americans recognize it
by its shape this is it right here
North Korea Germany
is this Canada
is that Canada uh close
they have a strong Russian influence
okay is it Syria
um no their last election they elected a
crazy person oh is it North Korea
Americans can name this country
Europe
[Music]
Jeremiah Wassa what once divided East
Germany and West Germany
see let's see all right and then the
water evaporated
they were United United Okay was it
right for George Clooney to lose the
role of Santa Claus for the harmful
things he said about Italian food yeah I
think George Clooney deserves to be
canceled for that
um and do you think he should apologize
I think he should yeah he should own up
to his wrongs when did you first hear
about it
um honestly I didn't know much about it
I heard on Twitter a little bit but I
didn't really look much into it I don't
really keep up with him as much
um what tweets did you see uh just like
people talking about canceling him and
just like him not apologizing for his
wrongs spaghetti gate yes yes the little
kid from Young Sheldon okay um he's
going to jail for tax evasion do you uh
think you deserves to be canceled no I
mean everybody make mistakes I mean he
know what he did you know what I'm
saying when I saw it I honestly was
shocked I was shocked because I wouldn't
expect young Sheldon to do that
what hey
there's a lot of stuff that'd be going
on in the world you know it's like I
really was shocked I kind of looked a
little bit into it you know what I'm
saying to see like what he what actually
did he do so yeah where do you look
Google so what are we talking about
everything so you know what I'm saying
yeah so you like to research things
before you jump on yeah I'm not gonna if
like I said if young Sheldon did the
crime you do the time but
I'm not here to judge anyone you know
what I'm saying but I did be nosy about
it though but you wouldn't speak on
something without doing the research
exactly
and you name the vice president United
States
oh boy what's his name while it's on
asking I know what he looks like what
does he look like gray hair gray hair
white guy black guy yeah he's so white
he's so white who is known as the
commander-in-chief
no idea
I mean if a person was
commander-in-chief what would their job
be
[Music]
give orders
this is why we have to pay our teachers
more money can you find India for us I
am going to say it's somewhere in this
direction I just don't know exactly
where
India would be here nope that's Japan
over here no over here no
we're here no that's Greenland can you
do us a favor sure and find India for us
on a map oh yeah
um I'm I'm Texas oh yeah that's where
Texas is right right here right that's
Texas congratulations yeah what are
people from India called
um
in the uh not indians
well yeah right sure
um people from India yeah Indonesian